[Musique]
le niveau d'imposition des revenus des
particuliers et plus élevés au Québec
que dans les autres provinces du Canada
et dans l'ensemble de l'OCDE le Québec
affiche le troisième niveau de charge
fiscale le plus élevé la CAC a promis de
réduire les impôts au cours de la
prochaine décennie avec nous pour en
parler Suzy saint-serni qui est
professionnel de recherche à la chair en
fiscalité en finance publique de
l'Université de Sherbrooke bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous avez comparé parce
que le gouvernement le goût aime bien
comparer la situation toujours à
l'Ontario vous avez comparé l'écart du
Québec avec l'Ontario sur les barèmes
d'imposition qu'est-ce que vous avez
constaté mais on a comparé plusieurs
choses dans l'étude on a fait plusieurs
constats mais notamment avec l'Ontario
concernant le barème d'imposition des
particuliers notamment quand on compare
le barème on peut voir
qu'il y a une bonne partie du temps dans
les taux marginaux d'imposition donc le
dernier dans leur taxé en fonction du
revenu posant ou la courbe merci la
courbe du Québec
bientôt en bleu donc et toujours plus
haute que le taux québécois en terme de
combiné Québec ou provincial fédéral et
toujours plus élevé que le taux ontarien
en début et à la fin donc pour les bords
revenus et les hauts revenus et les cars
le plus important se situe au début donc
beaucoup plus entre 20000 dollars et 80
mille dollars de revenus imposable c'est
là que les corps atteints les niveaux
les plus élevés soit 7 points de
pourcentage 7,5 points pourcentage et en
bas de 100000 en fait on voit les cas on
taxe beaucoup plus c'est vraiment oui
c'est vraiment jusqu'à 80 000 si on
regardait le pile poil d'écart ok donc
ce que vous constatez c'est que
les ménages moins entiers une bonne
partie de la classe moyenne la classe
moyenne élevée est plus taxée au Québec
quand l'Ontario là on parle pas des
services parce que c'est certain qu'on a
beaucoup de services on regarde juste
l'impôt qu'à promis des baisses d'impôts
que ça coûterait 7 milliards et demi
entre 2023 et 2026 rappelons un peu leur
engagement leur engagement ce qu'on
promis c'est de baisser les le premier
taux du barème d'imposition donc les
faire passer de le premier cas de 15 à
14 et le deuxième barème le deuxième
taux de 20 à 19 donc c'est ça
l'idée c'est justement de couvrir ces
gens-là donc ça donnerait une certaine
économie d'impôts il y a deux phases à
la baisse d'impôts il y en a promis
aussi pour beaucoup plus tard donc à
partir de 2027 maisons de coupe pas dans
l'étude d'accord ce qu'on cause c'est le
premier le premier baisse qu'on a vu le
tableau là j'allais pas vu passer
est-ce qu'on a le tableau oui bon on va
le regarder ensemble n'est pas assez de
15 à 14 degré à 19 et donc venez de dire
au complet pour la première année c'est
1.7 milliards le prochain tableau
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça représente
comme économie pour les différents
contribuables c'est ce qui est
intéressant de savoir comment est-ce que
ça donne dans les poches des
contribuables donc en fonction du revenu
ça va varier mais à 25000 dollars c'est
56 dollars d'économie d'impôts ça va
augmenter comme comme ça jusqu'à
94200 en 2022 pour un salaire de 94200
jusqu'à 764 la maximum d'économies
d'impôts sa plateforme à ce montant là
donc c'est des économies d'impôts qui
sont quand même c'est pas négligeables
c'est quand même une bonne économie
alors ça c'est l'engagement c'est la
promesse on verra comment ça va se
déployer dans les budgets à la chaire de
finance et de fiscalité publique vous
êtes vous êtes demandé si l'engagement
de la CAQ est vraiment le plus efficace
qu'on vient de voir et vous avez fait
d'autres scénarios pour le même coup on
va regarder un de plus près qu'est-ce
que vous proposez en fait nous on a on a
regardé plusieurs pour voir si il y a eu
moyen de faire mieux ou de faire
autrement faire mieux peut-être pas mais
il y a d'autres options ce qu'on a
regardé c'est cette fois là aussi offrir
une base d'impôts promis et deuxième
taux du barème donc viser la même
clientèle mais limiter cette baisse là
aux gens qui gagnent jusqu'à 80 000
dollars au lieu de se rendre à 92000
dollars en faisant ça ça nous permet de
dégager des sommes pour donner plus aux
gens qui ont moins de dollars on permet
donc une baisse d'un point 1,3 points
pourcentage de chacun des deux tours
ici ça donne des économies
supplémentaires une économie qui va être
plafonnée cette fois-là à 830 dollars et
après les gens qui vont l'économie va
être réduite jusqu'à un plancher de 327
dollars donc les tout le monde en
bénéfique les gens imposant mais moins
quand les revenus sont plus élevés
est-ce que c'est une mesure qui coûte
plus cher à l'État c'est vrai c'est
important c'est la même coup
naturellement toutes nos alternatives
ils sont faites au même coup donc on
fait on redessine un peu la façon dont
la baisse peut être fait pour arriver au
même coup pour arriver aussi à cibler
davantage la baisse c'est ça en fait on
cible davantage tout le monde là mon
cible de façon plus importante les gens
en devint et 80 mille dollars d'euros
parce que l'idée c'est aussi donc de
toucher les travailleurs de permettre
aux travailleurs d'économiser un peu sur
les impôts dans les autres voies que
vous proposez vous proposez qu'on le
travail par exemple sur la déduction
pour les travailleurs oui bah c'est une
autre option de dire si on voulait
cibler uniquement les gens qui gagnent
du revenu de travail qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire la façon de faire c'est
d'aller avec la déduction pour
travailler hard l'augmenter donc on
offre des économies d'impôts mais dans
ce cas-là uniquement au travailleur mais
ça permet d'en offrir davantage à chacun
des travailleurs donc c'est une autre
option qu'en fonction de ce que on veut
faire on peut il y a une panoplie de
possibilités naturelles
ça va dépendre des objectifs en fait
l'important qu'il faut retenir c'est que
que ce soit la promesse ou chacune des
options on cible la classe moyenne donc
en 2080 000 c'est vrai dans tous les cas
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça si on veut
plus les travailleurs il y a une option
possible si on veut toucher à tout le
monde on va regarder à toucher le barème
c'est plus visible aussi si on veut
cibler les écarts les plus importants on
le dit toutes les gagne toutes les
propositions le font excusez moi si on
veut plafonner et
compétences de la baisse soit moins
grande pour les plus hauts revenus mais
c'est possible aussi donc il y a
différentes options le gouvernement
a-t-il les moyens de remplir cet
engagement mais le gouvernement il faut
se rappeler qu'en campagne on dit que
qui est financerait cette baisse
d'impôts là en bassin les versements au
fond des générations par exemple pour
faire ça ils peuvent le faire mais il y
a des éléments préalables il faut
retrouver l'équilibre donc dans le
prochain budget il faudrait voir un plan
de retour à l'équilibre il faudrait voir
ce que les cibles de dettes sont
atteintes si oui est-ce qu'on en fixe de
nouvelles et pour en fixer de nouvelles
est-ce que quels font on a besoin à
mettre que l'argent on peut mettre dans
le fond des livraisons une fois qu'on a
dit ça si il y a trop de fonds oui on
peut l'utiliser à autre chose ce qui va
il voudrait peut-être le faire avec les
bases d'impôts c'est possible mais il y
a plusieurs éléments sinon ben peut-être
qu'il faut la retarder il y a plusieurs
options possibles
et c'est ce que nous verrons dans le
budget de Monsieur Girard qui sera
présenté
à la fin de l'hiver début du printemps
merci beaucoup Susie sincèrement merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI